هذه الخيام التي عددها 90 خيمه تضم في كل
خيمه ثلاث او اربع عائلات ايضا هناك خارج
الخيام عدد كبير من الاهالي والعائلات
تفترش الطرقات وتفترش العراء تنتظر دورها
بحصول على الخيام نشاهدها في الجهه
المقابله حقيقه الاعداد والاهالي بالاضافه
الى الاوضاع الانسانيه الصعبه نحن هنا هذه
احدى الخيام نستطيع ممكن ندخل للخيمه
هذه الخيام التي نشاهدها التي يقيم فيها
الاهالي حاول ان الوصول الى داخلها
والصوره هنا هي ابرز
كل ما تحتوي هذه الخيمه بعض الفرش
والبطانيات تفتقر الى
المدفاه او التدفئه او بعض الوسائل
العوازل للحمايه الاهالي من البرد الشديد
حقيقه في الساعات الليل درجات الحراره
تشتد برودتها وتصعب الجلوس في هذه الخيام
كان فيها الخيام وخارجها نحن مساء ليله
امس كنا هنا وكانت درجات الحراره شديده فش
البرد يعني لا يستطيع تحملها هؤلاء
الاطفال نشاهد هنا بالزاويه الاخرى
الاهالي الذين يفترشون الطرقات ينتظرون
دورهم بتقديم المساعدات ان كان خيام سالنا
الاهالي عن ابرز الاحتياجات التي
يحتاجونها قالوا لنا انها هي الخيام
بالاضافه الى تامين بعض الخدمات في هذا
المخيم من خزانات للمياه ودورات المياه
بالاضافه الى الخيام والبطانيات وحليب
الاطفال نشاهدنا عدد كبير من الاطفال
والنساء هم كانوا ناجين من الزلزال ولكنهم
باتوا ضحايا نقص الامكاني ات الانسانيه
وقله المساعدات الانسانيه من قبل المنظمات
ومن قبل الفرق الانسانيه